sur cette photo récente c'est une jeune
fille souriante marilyn avait 21 ans
elle est morte ce matin touché par un
tir en pleine tête
le drame s'est produit dans cette maison
peu avant minuit et c'est le compagnon
de la victime qui est l'auteur du coup
de feu mortel
mon fils il ya des rats chez lui puis il
a voulu tirer les rats avec une carabine
une 12 mm une vieille carabine quoi et
puis comme les rats était parti il a
voulu désarmer la carabine et le coût
des partis c'était involontaire
s'il en accident bête les médecins n'ont
pas réussi à sauver la jeune femme qui
est morte à l'hôpital de nevers des
suites de sa blessure
son compagnon a été placé en garde à vue
en état de choc et l'anéantir
en plus ce qu'elle était enceinte avait
un petit bébé de cinq mois fille de
trois ans et puis là vous avez c'était
un petit garçon en plus t'es été heureux
comme tout accident bête après une
dizaine d'heures de garde à vue l'auteur
du coup de feu est ressorti libre de la
gendarmerie
une autopsie ainsi qu'une expertise
balistique ont été ordonnées par la
justice afin de déterminer les
circonstances précises de cette mort
dramatique